bom dia pessoal ela gente ligada à
silvio bom pra quem não sabe a láurea
camila ação no canal modo esse 38 e ela
já tem um canal há quatro anos da grife
issa então desde 2012 é bom com um
pouquinho pra gente como é que veio a
idéia de criar o canal de onde isso veio
então a gente sempre gostou de assistir
vídeos no youtube acompanhar o youtube
eu acho que serei o filme e do nada
assim foi uma coisa bem espontânea é de
início a gente não contava pra ninguém
porque tinha muita vergonha e também
porque achava que a gente razoável pelas
colegas de turma
mas foi totalmente contrário ele sempre
dar o maior apoio aliás ele nunca foi
isolada por causa do nosso canal sempre
quando esconda para as pessoas elas
demonstram muito interessados fazem
várias perguntas porque é uma coisa
relativamente nova então ninguém sabe
muito bem como é que funciona é e o
casal começou a crescer ea gente foi
gostando mais frequentemente e ovídio
problema as organizações e os
comentários ficarão cada vez mais
positivos legal e bom você já estão a
rede novamente um bom tempo no youtube
vocês conseguiram ver assim esse
crescimento dele tal como é o youtube
hoje em dia no mundo do trabalho então
quando ele de que o canal em 2012 e
ignora nenhum pouco conhecido como ele é
hoje
então ninguém sabia mesmo como é que
funcionava o que acontecia muito menos
não viu isso como um trabalho
só que de 2002 para cá eo youtube
cresceu muito e as pessoas começaram a
ver que ele poderia sim ser uma
profissão
então as pessoas começaram a pagar seus
empregos na faculdade eu nem começar a
faculdade da cidade cá só ao youtube
isso deu muito certo porque os milhares
de pessoas que trabalham com o youtube o
maior clube do mundo que é o pelo pai
ele tem aproximadamente 7 a 45 milhões
de inscritos e 1.014 ele ganhou em torno
de 7,5 milhões de dólares que é uma boa
quantia de dinheiro é verdade
antigamente os vídeos no youtube ele era
mas do blog as pessoas ligavam a câmera
e falavam sobre o assunto mas o youtube
evoluiu muito e com isso novas
categorias surgiram como maquiagem moda
culinária vídeo-aulas enfim uma
variedade imensa que agrada todo o
público e os clubes jogando uma certa
importância e foram se espalhando para
outras áreas para o youtube alcançaram 1
livros participaram de filmes
propagandas de tv programas de tv em uma
propaganda está passando agora da coca
cola que tem quatro e oito bits lucas
engel cristina figueiredo felipe
castanhar ea bruna vieira ajudado
entrevista propaganda na tv e também
eles expandiram o teatro tem vários e
outubro estão usando peças de teatro
pelo brasil inteiro aqui em porto alegre
já teve o felipe neto a criança veio
gente do céu o lula tá vendo também
e também há muitas e outubro estão
lançando coleções de maquiagem button se
lançando marca de roupas youtube viu que
estava dando muito certo então resolveu
patrocinar divulgar os próprios em
outubro então isso aumentou a
popularidade do youtube e do youtube e
em esse propagandas mais nos estados
unidos por exemplo outdoor na times
square ou laterais do metrô aí em 2015
a casa branca do estado decidiu um
evento de entrevistas onde ele chamar
alguns tubos para entrevistar o
presidente dos estados unidos barack
obama e isso mostra que o youtube são
sim grandes influenciadores da mídia e
vocês duas que têm idade mais ou menos
todo mundo aqui 15 16 17 14 já
consideram o youtube com uma profissão
um trabalho assim
apesar de dizerem que é só postar um
vídeo online fazer vídeo é fácil eo
youtube é sim uma profissão é um
trabalho remunerado que requer esforço
criativo tempo que tipo por exemplo a
gente é meio complicado ver se consegue
o youtube ea escola e de vez em quando o
canal fica de lado pra gente focar na
nossa prioridade que a nossa educação e
também requer muita paciência para
editar os vídeos postados no youtube que
de vez em quando tem um tempinho e não é
só ligar a câmera e sair falando
qualquer coisa tem que saber o que atrai
o público com o prender ele muitas
pessoas acham que trabalhar é só ficar
num escritório estão papéis por exemplo
o hospital examinando pacientes mas é
muito mais que isso o mundo está
evoluindo muito e o trabalho evoluiu
junto então agora não precisa mais uma
faculdade para trabalhar
se vocês acham que é tão fácil no
youtube e tem está um vídeo e postar no
youtube é bem competitiva
bom então vocês duas
hoje em dia a gente vê muito nas redes
sociais o reitor as pessoas que vem
criticar o trabalho falar mal às vezes
sem as vezes argumentos bons e tudo mais
é como o que vocês lidam com isso como
vocês começarão a ver disputas
esse é um problema que eu tenho que
enfrentar então acho que tudo o que foi
fazer a sua vida sempre vai ter alguém
pra criticar pra te julgar e quando
posta um vídeo no youtube principalmente
vão ter comentários negativos
a principal coisa que tem que fazer é
ignorar uma coisa que a gente não fazia
no início a gente iria todos os
comentários e escondia todos os
negativos obviamente ampla que ficam
muito indignada que pessoas que a gente
nem conhecia falava coisas estão erradas
e às vezes maldosos a nosso respeito
só que ao longo do tempo é amadurecendo
a gente percebeu que não vale a pena
ficar batendo fogo com fogo e que a
melhor coisa que a gente podia fazer é
ignorar e deletar esses comentários tá
então tem essa parte que é uma parte de
mim eu tive e tudo mais
manzi do amor dos fãs dos recados que
vocês recebem comentários como vocês se
sentem com isso sim é realmente muito
legal tudo isso que acontece com a gente
por exemplo entrar no nosso canal e ver
comentários tão legais entrar no nosso
meio antes hebe meio vários e mails de
pessoas que a gente nem conhece que
falam que gostaram muito do nosso vídeo
am que aquele vídeo alegrou o dia delas
ou que ajudou de uma certa forma ou
simplesmente agradecendo por a gente ter
um canal e postar o vídeo é realmente
muito legal e com isso a gente viu que
ele tinha uma certa influência então a
gente usava uma coisa positiva foi a
gente gravou dois vídeos que se orgulha
um deles é um recado para todos
adolescentes onde a gente falou sobre a
importância do amor próprio tanto estima
das anos segurando os seguranças que o
adolescente espaço
por exemplo agora a gente está
ultrapassando assim o medo que a gente
quer falar em público eu por exemplo sou
uma pessoa muito tímida eu acho que a
mensagem que ele sempre tentou passar
para as pessoas é que não deixem que as
suas inseguranças impeçam vocês fazerem
que vocês quiserem
se vocês querem que é um canal no
youtube falar em crise não fiquem com
medo do que as pessoas vão falar pensar
se vai ter inscritos ou não porque se
realmente é o que menos importa
e é isso que quero fazer tem que ir lá e
fazer e outro vídeo foi o que você quer
ser quando crescer
o que a gente está falando sobre as
coisas na opção que é uma coisa que a
gente está passando agora é a gente
conta
experiência levanta a mão aí quem não
sabe o que fazer quando crescer
é o bastante para a gente também não
sabe o que a gente quer e dos pais que
não dão liberdade de profissional porque
isso é uma que vai contra a gente sempre
incentiva as pessoas a seguirem seus
sonhos e serem que elas querem ser e
pensar que uma coisa tão simples
compositor um vídeo no youtube pode
mudar o dia de alguém é realmente muito
gratificante
e pensar que a gente é responsável por
isso o nosso canal foi crescendo ea
gente foi sendo reconhecida na rua as
pessoas param para pedir autógrafos e
tirar fotos
como foi isso de primeira o primeiro que
apareceu como é que vocês viram
espero simplesmente no notório assim ele
estava no show do andrea chan e no rio
de janeiro uma menina nos parou para
pedir autógrafo e eu não sabia como
fazer isso que eu nunca tinha dado uma
boa influência do que escrever no papel
é a letra saiu fêmeas experiência bem
bacana legal e 2012 com certeza que
nunca ia imaginar que ele tinha pessoas
queridas e parado na rua ea tirar fotos
enfim e muito menos a gente imaginar que
teria que hoje falando no texas que é
uma das coisas mais gratificantes
acontecer com a gente por causa do canal
a alegria de muito obrigado porque o
meia tcheco ainda serei obrigado e por
último a gente queria pedir para tirar
uma selva que vocês acham
todo mundo junto dele só que em
determinado que vai parar no site do
canal vai ter 40 mil pessoas ea gente
não tá nem aí eu não sei se vai dar
muito certo é tão 129 está obrigada
gente já